we're he lying you may know us as food
beasts GQ sent us around the country to
find the coolest bars and restaurants
this is your guide to Washington DC the
district where everyone feels less than
represented but city's real nice and
everybody gets paid more so [ __ ] them we
lit up the whole group right outside
Italy diplomat then headed off our first
stop the Jefferson hotel this is a
really nice hotel super swanky five
stars legit five stars not like Yelp
five stars we're in a private room they
gave us because we're too rowdy scared
off all the nice customers we're in the
book room it's modeled after Jefferson's
bedroom it has a bunch of old books and
stuff we left a little surprise in one
of them find where it is these might be
some of the best drinks we've had the
entire trip next we walk to Lincoln on
the way we stopped at some sort of
opening sequence to house of cards it
was pretty cool we got to Lincoln and
that place was totally different seemed
like a little more modern but it was
really cool and everybody was happy
Morgan told us that the mac and cheese
and the punch are the go-to items here
so we ordered seven of each this is me
drinking out of the bowl
here's Eli drinking out of the bowl and
Morgan everybody drank out of the bowl
after Lincoln we called a couple of
movers because it was kind of a far walk
also the temperature was dropping a
world from California so a bunch of
[ __ ] when it comes to the cold
weather we pulled up to this place that
looked like a house
it was ass it's called compass rose
there's a really cool little bar
restaurant tucked inside this old house
they serve a bunch of like multicultural
food it's kind of like they have items
from everywhere all over the world and
stuff that's what multicultural means
right oh yeah that orange wine was
delicious here in DC this place is a
must if everyone could get something
different everyone will like it right
around the corner from compass rose this
place called bar Pilar it's named after
the boat from the old man and sea I
don't know what that is cuz I don't read
it's very nautical it has cool [ __ ] all
over the place with some Hemingway
daiquiri oh [ __ ] now we're doing high
kicks
I ripped my jeans after bar Pilar we
went to Stoney's Sonia is just like a
nice little DC dive bar barely DC
legends hang out there you know
journalists under arrest Thompson Ritter
- it tunnel wings it was kind of nice to
end at a place that wasn't super
pretentious it was just a good place
next time you're in DC check out these
five spots and tell us what you think if
not use yo
you